ich habe vor ein paar tagen video auf
youtube gesehen in dem revier bilder von
youtube auf einer webseite hochgeladen
hat die diese youtuber dem aussehen nach
bewertet wie heiß es konkreter leute sex
oft etwas
ich bin hart hässlicher spaß in der tat
die website heißt auf jeden fall hatte
die who hat die fischl intelligence wird
die seite hat jura und scale of montana
da hatte ich leider eine 6 heißt ich war
nicht so schön wir sehen hier schon
leute eingeblendet also beispielsweise
sie hat eine neun von zehn kann ich
nicht drauf klicken
es ist eigentlich genauso wie hot puncto
von damals nur dass die website hat
irgendwie gesperrt wurde aber ich würde
sagen wir lagern gar nicht mehr lange im
heißen brei herum ich glaub mal direkt
das erste foto hoch und zwar ist dieses
hier von bwin zeit war ich dachte wenn
er da und video gemacht aber dann
nämlich doch in der zeit die man als
erstes ich habe einen seiner wirklich
schönsten bilder herausgesucht sechs von
zehn
reviers mit zum bild genauso hübsch wie
ich mit einem normalen bild wenn ich den
hut hätte würde ich den jetzt
polizeirevier weil das ist echt stark
als nächstes bild habe ich eins
vorbereitet von einer youtube drin da
muss ganz ehrlich sagen zu der schau ich
hoch da er orientiere ich mich ein
bisschen dran was was content angeht was
qualität angeht und zwar babys beauty
palace ich weiß nicht was sie da gerade
im gesicht hat aber anscheinend ist es
in make up fail
ja oder oder halt scheiße ich würde
sagen wir schauen mal welche bewertung
dieses bild von der baby denn hier auf
der website bekommt 8
bibi ist mit diesem gesicht zwei punkte
hübscher als als ich mit nem nummer ein
gesicht
wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern nicht
zufrieden
als nächstes bild habe ich ein youtuber
ausgewählt den ich in letzter zeit
tatsächlich ab zuschauer muss ich ganz
ehrlich gesagt zu geben und zwar kuchen
tv
wir schauen mal wie er bewertet wird
sechs von zehn kuchen du bist genau so
hässlich wie ich hey hey der nächste
youtuber den ich vorbereitet habe ist
ein youtuber der sich häufig darüber
beschwert dass zuschauer was in seinem
auto machen und auch schon oft
angekündigt hat dass er sein neues auto
nicht mehr zeigen wollte dann jedoch
trotzdem 30.000 videos zu seinem neuen
auto gemacht hat und bilder damit
täglich hochlädt und zwar wesens denn
wer kann es denn sonst sein freunde
krieg ja auch wunderschön getroffen acht
von zehn dicker was natürlich auch
applaus du du bist hübscher als ich und
kuchen allerdings bist du auf einer
ebene mit diesem bild von baby also
ja aber acht von zehn kann man mal
machen beim nächsten bild habe ich eine
youtuber ausgewählt der derzeit viel zu
schön wäre tatsächlich für diese ganze
website deswegen habe ich ein etwas
älteres bild von ihm genommen und zwar
in scope in den zeiten wo er noch
außerhalb insel an der stelle schöne
grüße an dich nico m ich leide jetzt mal
eben dieses bild hier hoch und wird
das ist
bisher glaube ich der schlechteste score
die das ganze video hier sollen
natürlich überhaupt nicht böse sein oder
gegen irgendwelche youtuber gehen ich
möchte nicht schon wieder gebiete
anfangs irgendwelches da magazine
ankommen und sagen ich hätte streit mit
anderen leuten das ist alles nur humor
deswegen würde ich sagen wir nehmen für
nico einfach nochmal das erste bild was
kommen wenn man ins top 21
genau das auch wunderschönes bild meine
wer sonst und ferne wenn wir so ein
altes bild nehmen also ich würde sagen
meine damen und herren das neue bild ist
drin
die website lädt jetzt gerade und wir
schauen mal die quartiere 6 nico du bist
genau so hässlich wie ich und kuchen tv
und jetzt meine damen und herren kommen
wir auch tatsächlich schon zum letzten
youtuber denen ich mir ausgesucht habe
muss ganz ehrlich sagen finde ich vom
konto der ist er nicht zu meinen dingen
vom aussehen her ist setzt audi für
beiden dinge eigentlich kommt kompletter
voll spaß kontrast meine damen und
herren wir 44
damit bin ich hässlicher als dieses bild
ich bin hässlicher als nico vor 30
jahren
hässlicher als revier hier echt lassen
ich bin ich bin echt hässlich